okay so i'm mid moving so it's very
echoey here but i'll tell you guys
why i got banned on my tick tock account
okay so the last couple of months the
left will like mass report my videos
whenever i say anything that they just
don't agree with
and
mind you the videos would get taken down
randomly
and then i would get in trouble i could
be banned from posting for a couple days
or whatever but even if you get the
video for swords so if you appeal the
video and say hey people are just mass
reporting because they're being [ __ ]
tick tock
will still count it as a strike against
you because i think it's like automatic
or something i don't know how it works
so before i got banned i was on my last
strike and the crazy thing is the video
that gave me my last strike tick-tock
looked at and restored the video but
still told me i was on my last strike
i'm like why
why why am i on my last strike now some
people would be a little more careful
not me i was like you know what i'm
gonna say what i'm gonna say i'm gonna
post it i'm gonna post whatever happens
happens so the video that got me banned
permanently i think i'm not i'm not
positive but i have a gut
feeling that it was this one basically
so i was in shortage this town in london
okay i'm american but i live in london
and i was doing public interviews
and i was attacked by a land whale okay
so doing this interview this woman
kept following me and i'm like lady you
can get out of the shot
or you can be in the shot but stop
attacking my camera man stop coming at
me like if you don't be in it
that's fine
but
like you're following me at this point
so so in the interview this whale land
whale knocks the mic out of my hand okay
and
she starts saying i'll have you
i'll have you you slag you slang and i'm
like oh god and so i'm i'm like looking
at this crazy [ __ ] i'm like
one i'm like you're a grown ass woman
what are you doing and then
and then she's calling me slag which i
didn't know what that meant at the time
i'm not british so i'm like but i knew
it was an insult i knew i was being
insulted okay so i said you're a whale
you're a whale you're a male and this is
the crazy thing one of us said something
that was true okay
objectively she was a bigger woman
she was a bigger woman okay
you can see maybe the whale was too far
but she was a bigger woman
slag that's like me calling you a [ __ ]
that's just an insult but a whale is a
beautiful majestic creature
and yeah i guess tick tock even though
she assaulted me
and
aunt insulted me first i still got
banned
that's the crazy thing
free pearly things free just pearly
things give me my account back